est-ce que d'ici quelques semaines
quelques mois on pourrait donner la
permission à certaines personnes de
faire les magasins de voyages et de
serrer leurs grands-parents de nombreux
pendant que le laisse la population
continue avec les mesures de confinement
et distanciation physique pour contrôler
l'épidémie
c'est ce qui arriverait avec les
passeports et militaires lui par ce
sport qui accorderait plus de liberté
aux personnes qui ont les bons anticorps
dans le sens contre les coronavirus
qu'elle s'était des malades ou
asymptomatiques
si ça sonne comme la science fiction
c'est parce que c'est encore la science
fiction pour le moment même si le
déploiement des passeports immunitaire
est complètement hypothétique
l'idée de ce site et beaucoup de
discussions très sérieuses partout à
travers le monde dans les dernières
semaines y compris au sein de certains
gouvernements
dans une lettre la maire de la capitale
propose au premier ministre que dans un
premier temps seuls les parisiens
immunisé contre le coc u19 et le droit
de sortir
munis d'un certificat le 24 avril
dernier l'organisation mondiale la santé
statuer sur les passeports limite à
temps qu'on se repose si on développe
oui ou non une immunité à la coved 19
il sera trop tôt pour établir un système
de passeport immunitaire notre corps
développe plusieurs types d'anticorps
contre la combi de 19
on sait pas s'il y en a certains qui
nous empêche d'attraper la maladie une
deuxième fois
ni lesquels ni combien de temps cette
immunité du ray ni à quelle
concentration on peut les détecter dans
le sens ni si ça nous empêche d'être
contagieux pour les autres et les fameux
tests sérologiques ce qui permet de
détecter les anticorps et qui sont pas
encore fiables à 100%
oui donc j'ai mayotte s'il ya des faux
négatifs
ça voudrait dire qu'on pourrait empêcher
de travailler certaines personnes qui
seraient immunisés
mais s'il ya des faux positifs c'est
encore plus risqué ça voudrait dire
qu'on pourrait donner plus de liberté à
certaines personnes qui sont vulnérables
et c'est pour ça que dans les
laboratoires la course continue
il y a plusieurs pays plusieurs
compagnies privées et gouvernement qui
travaillent extrêmement dur sur ce test
tout le monde comprend que c'est notre
billet de sortie de la situation
actuelle je crois bon on n'a pas
beaucoup de cristal je crois qu'on aura
quelque chose appréciable bientôt et
donc toutes ces questions qu'on se pose
actuellement sur les politiques de santé
qui devrait entourer la mise en oeuvre
les questions éthiques les questions de
discriminations il faut poser ses
questions
maintenant si j'ai voulu avoir la vie
d'une bio édition sur la question c'est
que même dans un scénario où on aurait
toutes les connaissances et la meilleure
technologie en moins le concept je pense
paris minuteur peut paraître très
trouble je pense que les gens sont
parfois choqués par cette idée parce
qu'on a tellement l'habitude de lutter
contre une discrimination sur une page
biologie génétique base de santé on ne
peut pas contrôler notre immunité contre
la folie donc ces avantages vont être
perçue par le public comme une
discrimination non justifiées c'est la
première fois qu'on se retrouve dans
cette situation précise
mais si on remonte dans le temps on peut
quand même tracé certains parallèles
avec des situations dû penser et
identifier certaines personnes selon des
critères sanitaires poursuivre ou
restreindre leurs déplacements
perso ça date pas d'hier
à la fin du 19e siècle on commence à
mettre en place des quarantaines dans ce
qu'on appelait des lazarets dont il a
adressé des baisers dit qu'ils étaient
vraiment pensé pour accueillir les
populations qui revenait des bateaux et
les autres organes ce qui se développe
c'est ce qu'on appelle les patentes de
santé l'onglet avril en fait ce sont des
documents qu'on commence à développer
qui sont écrire départ par les consuls
du pays d'origine
c'est un document qui donne au co
capitaine du bateau pour assurer l'état
sanitaire en fait du corps d'origine
et ça c'est les documents qui doit être
la base pour permettre aux bateaux
d'entrer de ne pas rentrer dans un peu
en gros si votre facteur de santé et des
salles c'est le fameux drapeau jaune
houlette en carotène et ensuite on en a
grand place à l'échelle des individus
des examens bactériologiques et engrossé
ces examens au début du 20e siècle qui
vous permettait de sortir ou une passe
en firent du bateau pour ne pas sentir
d'une aile darksiders le hic c'est que
souvent on se servait de repère pour
très objectifs comme la propreté des
vêtements par exemple pour filtrer les
migrants choisir les bons travailleurs
ensuite la science a progressé et le
vaccin s'est imposée comme une nouvelle
méthode de contrôle et de stopper les
équidés
[Musique]
vaccination devient à partir des années
quarante puis notamment pour la variole
ça devient une obligation pour déplacer
donc avant on empêcher les gens qui en
revenait de pays où il y avait un risque
de compromis nation de la variable de la
fièvre jaune ou les empêcher d'entrer
après ce qui se fait c'est d'obliger les
personnes qui parlent à avoir un
certificat et pour revenir à avoir à
montrer qu'elles ont été vaccinés pour
gérer la circulation des personnes
le carnet de vaccination c'est sûrement
un outil plus objectif que la propriété
des vêtements mais celia miralles bout
il m'expliquait que c'est pas parce
qu'on est les bons outils scientifiques
que les contrôles arbitraire ou
discriminatoires disparaissent comme par
magie on le voit encore aujourd'hui une
épidémie
ça révèle ou même ça accentue des
injustices qui sont en attente
on le vit au milieu du 19e siècle à la
nouvelle orléans qui était aux prises
avec des épidémies de fièvre jaune les
esclaves qui s'en sortent qui
survivaient étaient immunisés et leur
valeur augmenter à mesure leurs
propriétaires qui fait qu'il ya
certaines personnes qui cherchaient à
s'infecter volontairement au risque de
leur vie pour améliorer leur sort on
n'est vraiment pas dans un contexte
similaire aujourd'hui sauf que si jamais
on est immunisé à la coved 19 et ça
confère des libertés supplémentaires il
ya certaines personnes qui vont intenter
souto infecté aussi et ça c'est vraiment
pas une bonne idée
on ne sait pas quel impact la co vite va
avoir sur nous comme personne
individuelle
il ya des personnes qui souffrent très
peu et d'autres qui m'a donc aller
simple été intentionnellement peut avoir
des conséquences extrêmement graves pour
la personne individuelle
c'est ce qui fait que les décisions
qu'on doit prendre actuellement sont si
délicate
il ya une tension constante entre les
libertés individuelles et l'intérêt
collectif
tout comme d'une tension entre les
intérêts économiques et les intérêts
sanitaire relancer l'économie c'est
l'argument principal de celui qui
souhaite instaurer des passeports
immunitaire comme le chili qui va de
l'avant avec les premiers passeports au
monde malgré les avertissements
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
santé de l'économie
souvent été évoqué un temps d'épidémie
est pas toujours au bénéfice de la santé
des populations pour penser quand même
qu'au 19e siècle par exemple le fait de
mettre en place une quarantaine de
bloquer tout le monde et ce qui se
passait c'est qu'on empêchait tout le
monde allait travailler on empêcher
aussi tout le monde d'avoir un revenu et
à des famines énorme qui ont été
provoqués à moscou par exemple un
univers où une fait ses preuves au
niveau que toute la ville et les rançons
mort de femmes si jamais on prouve qu'on
peut devenir immunisé à la coved 19 et
qu'on détecte les bancs anticorps avec
des tests assez sensible est ce que
c'est ce que je dis suis instauré le
système de passeport immunitaire
c'est-à-dire si la seule façon de
revenir un petit peu au travail pour le
meilleur intérêt de tous et d'utiliser
ses fastes entérologie
ça sera justifiée mais juste d'une
manière temporaire il faut que toutes
les règles derrière c'est passeport
sérologique soit à communiquer
clairement au public la transparence
c'est la première chose à à garder en
tête
deuxièmement il faut que ces règles
soient cohérentes et appliquée d'une
manière équitable à travers la société
troisièmement il faut faire un effort
d'éducation pour faire comprendre au
public
en quoi ça sert à tous oui il y aura des
personnes qui tirait son confinement
qu'on dit qu'il voit les autres sortir
et c'est vraiment un sentiment de
l'injustice un intuitif mais on est tous
intelligents et rationnel on peut
comprendre en permettant une partie de
revenir un lit économique
ça va finalement servir à tous elle
permettra nous mêmes en campement de
sortir plus vite dans la communauté
scientifique beaucoup s'entend pour dire
qu'il est trop tôt qui encore trop
d'inconnues dans l'équation pour pouvoir
utiliser les passeports immunitaire sans
risquer de relancer l'épidémie si
l'alternance entre le confinement et le
déconfinement et la distanciation
physiques doivent se prolonger plusieurs
mois pouvoir au dessus de renom ce qu'on
souhaite pas mais mieux vaut voir venir
et réfléchir aux manières les plus
justes dans l'histoire et un tel système
puis si jamais ça se concrétise pas ça
fait quand même des très beaux scénarios
pour alimenter vos cinq à six heures en
vidéoconférence
[Musique]